il préfère voilà alors on en guise et où
elle chantait
pendant que les étoiles chantait et ben
nous on avait un petit dessin de
wolinski je te crois pas je crois pas
c'est pas possible ça ils n'ont pas pu
faire un truc pareil on n'a même pas dit
que l'émission continuer après soir 3
mais on n'est pas en retard mais ça
c'est pas possible ça
et non mais là il faut faire un scandale
à l'antenne non mais je veux dire il
faut hurler sur un coup comme ça non
alors là alors là je le prend très mal
et annoncé que tu économises un thème
donc smartphones en france ayant gelé
par tous invités écoute j'étais dans les
temps on était en avance dans ce cas oui
c'est moi je suis réalisé sans valise et
jusqu'en des comics
si le journal de soir3 ne dis pas que
alors la [ __ ] bon ben on est désolé
non non non non mais ils nous ont même
pas laisser bon le problème c'est qu'on
devait dire on se retrouve tout de suite
après soir 3 et tout est là ils
balancent soir 3 et personne ne sait que
nous on continue l'émission après soir
fois c'est incroyable ça ceo journal ils
sont des chiens non mais attends on
n'était pas en retard là on a fait une
bonne quinzaine minutes à temps parce
que s'achevait
il
nous avons
aucun parti pour une heure on s'était
quitté un petit peu brutalement tout à
l'heure mais c'est pas grave pour ceux
qui prendraient l'antenne maintenant je
rappelle qu'on est avec paolo conte et
où on avait un petit peu froid ces
derniers temps à paris alors on s'est
payé une petite balade dans le piémont
ce qui n'empêche que le titre de la
chanson de paul okon tc l'iim permet à
billy en français les imperméables par
le comté